- My dad's a Holocaust survivor
and the one thing he
always talked about
in the Holocaust was that
it was really difficult
to find good weed.
So the way I honor the
memory of the fallen Jews
is that I was going to
smuggle these pot gummy bears
into Sydney, Australia.
(techno music)
Thank you everybody
If you don't know,
here's what the show is.
It's just a bunch of people
and we're all
telling true stories.
- [Host] Ladies and
gentlemen, Ari Shaffir.
(crowd cheering)
- So my story's this,
I went to Australia.
Has anyone ever
been to Australia?
(crowd cheers)
You have really,
when were you there?
- [Woman From
Audience] 10 years ago.
- 10 years ago, how
long was the flight?
- [Woman From Audience] Forever.
- Forever, yeah.
You gotta consider
killing yourself.
My flight was 13 hours.
It's so fucking long.
What were you on?
- [Man From Audience] A 747.
- 747? No.
That's not what I
was talking about.
(crowd laughing)
- I can see how you would think
that's what I was
talking about, but no.
What I said "what are you on,"
I mean what drug did
you take to survive
the 13 hours in a 747.
Nothing, you got drunk,
did you do anything?
- [Man From Audience]
I had a drink.
- Okay that's fair
that's a drug too.
I take pot cookies with me.
People take anything.
I've had friends take like,
you know sleeping pills,
a lot of people take sleeping
pills before they go.
My one friend took coke.
(crowd laughing)
I was like, dude
do what you want,
but that seems like the
wrong time to take coke.
(crowd laughing)
So I take pot cookiies with me,
that's what I do,
I take pot cookies.
And that's the best thing
about living in Los Angelos
is you just go to the
store and buy pot cookies.
They come in wrappers
so you can tell
how many calories are in there.
And whether or not
they're gluten free.
We live in the future you guys,
where we are is the future,
it's the greatest thing.
So I took these pot
cookies with me.
I took them all
out of the wrapper.
And I put 'em in a
Tupperware container.
And I had my friend's wife
write on the Tupperware box,
"We miss you honey enjoy
the cookies, love Mom."
Yeah, and I got on PTSA
'cus they don't so shit
and so we're sitting
there, me and my friend,
and we got bumped
up to first class.
It was so fucking awesome.
13 hours in first class.
It's one of those things
where they give you full beds.
They give you pajamas
before you get on the plane.
Pajamas and two socks to
masturbate into, I assumed.
(crowd laughing)
But two, two masturbation socks.
The luxury on Quantas oh.
So anyway we took off and
the seat belt light went off
and as soon as it went
off and went to my friend,
"Hey you ready for
some pot cookies?"
And I cracked open the
Tupperware and the reek of
marijuana just filled up the
entire first class cabin.
(crowd laughing)
It was like an
Iron Maiden poster
the way it was all fucking
coming out of there.
My friend was like,
"Dude what the fuck,
"put that away what
are you doing?"
And I was like, "Oh
shit, eat some, hurry!"
And I ate as much as
I could and I shut it.
And from then on whenever
I had to get more
I would go to the bathroom.
And I would open it
right by the toilet.
I'd flush a bunch of
times to clear the air.
I don't know how science works,
but it seems like
that should work.
(crowd laughing)
Still even then, when I got out
if someone was waiting for me
I'd be like, "Hey I just
took like a really minty
"dump in there so I'm sorry."
So it was great the
whole flight was amazing.
We landed I had three
pot cookies left over.
So I ate one, I gave
one to my friend,
and I took the last one
I just threw it away
in the airplane bathroom.
Look at how hurt you are look.
I had a lot of pot
cookies the whole time.
I was worried, 'cus
they make you fill out
these forms of what
produce you're bringing in
so I thought maybe they
had drug dogs or something.
I don't know, I just got scared.
And they actually
did have drug dogs
so I was like "Okay good."
So that was like five years ago.
Cut to last October,
I just went again.
And this time I took
with me pot gummy bears.
Yeah the technology
has improved.
(crowd laughing)
Los gumies hermanos.
They're amazing.
And for seven dollars you
can get a cherry flavored
gummy bear that'll fuck
you up for five hours.
Changes the game on
flights, make it way better.
There's no more bad
flights after that.
There's no more bad flights.
You can get stuck in
between two fat dudes,
and instead of being
upset you're just like,
"You guys are so soft."
(crowd laughing)
"How did you get that soft?
"You're the softest two people
I've ever met in my life."
It's awesome.
So this time I did not get
bumped up to first class.
I just flew regular,
peasant class.
And it was great, but the
pot gummy bears were amazing.
So I slept for like eight
hours of the trip this time.
And so when I landed I had
seven pot gummy bears left over.
And I went to throw them away
again when we were landing
I wanted to chuck 'em,
but then I got to the bathroom
and I thought about my dad.
And my dad's a Holocaust
survivor, for real.
He's 81, and the one thing
he always talked about
in the Holocaust was that
it was really difficult
to find good weed.
(crowd laughing)
So the way I honor the
memory of the fallen Jews
is that I was going to
smuggle these pot gummy bears
into Sydney, Australia.
That's how I would never forget.
So here's my plan, I
came up with a plan.
I had these macadamia
nuts in my bag.
And I was gonna say if the
drug dog smelled anything
I was just gonna say
they were smelling
the macadamia nuts.
That's it, that's the plan.
(crowd laughing)
When you hear it out loud,
it doesn't sound
that good at all,
but man I was so high
when I came up with it
it seemed like a perfect plan.
And super hilarious.
So you get out and
as you get into line,
they put you in
this custom's line.
And you put your bags down
and they have this dog,
this Jack Russell terrier
and he's wearing a uniform.
And they bring this
dog, they take it
and they bring it by your bag.
And this dog, let's say
this was the bag it was in,
and the pot gummy
bears were right there.
This dog went right
to that pocket
and starts going like that.
Just starts tapping
at it with his paw.
And in my head I'm thinking,
"Get the fuck out of here."
"Dog are you kidding
me right now?
That's the worst place
possible for you to be.
That's where I keep my drugs."
(crowd laughing)
I'm trying to be cool,
I'm trying to be like,
"Great architecture they
have here, it's so amazing."
Wow, cool.
So anyway the guy
goes, "Wait here."
And he goes and takes the dog
to smell a bunch of
other people's bags.
Dog smells nothing.
Just does figure eights
in between their bags.
Can't wait to get
back to my bag.
It's like a treat for him.
"Fuckin' let's do this."
He was running this way.
And went right back to it and
starts pawing at it again.
At this point I'm pouring sweat.
I'm like this is how
Locked Up Abroad starts.
You know what I mean?
Some asshole trying to smuggle
35 dollars worth of weed
onto another continent.
Blaming his Holocaust
survivor father.
He's really just a cheap Jew.
And so the guy, he
looks at me and he goes,
"What's going on in the bag?"
And I was like, "I
have macadamia nuts.
"I think the dog, okay
macadamia nuts have a pungent
"(sighs) what I
believe is happening
"is that the dog with
his keen sense of smell
"went by and 'cus the
macadamia nuts I have
"that the dog is
triggered by that
"and macadamia
nuts is my answer.
"Macadamia nuts."
And he just looks
at me, he just goes,
"No he's not trying to
smell for macadamia nuts."
I was like, "Oh fuck, why
didn't I research this?
"The wi-fi costs seven
dollars for an hour.
"I totally could
have gotten it."
And he goes, "They're
just trying to smell for
"fruit and for drugs."
And in my head I was thinking
like, "Oh fuck, fruit.
"I had so much access to that."
He goes, "Do you have
any fruit in there?"
And I was like, "No."
It was so easy they were giving
away bananas on the plane.
I was like, "I'm good I
got my macadamia nuts."
So I didn't take any.
And at this point I'm like,
okay I'm going to jail.
There's no way around it.
I'm going to an Australian jail.
I've never heard
about Australian jails
maybe they're okay,
maybe they're bad.
I would have heard
about them if they were
exceptionally bad.
They started as a prison colony,
they probably got jails really
well down at that point.
They probably know how to do it,
but I just got calm.
Like at some point when you
know you're getting caught
you don't even get
nervous anymore.
It's just going to happen.
You know?
I love how all the
black people are like,
"Yeah that is how
you get arrested."
You guys are all talking.
I made sure to
look away from you
when I was talking about arrest,
but then I was like they
look like they know.
(crowd laughing)
They really were looking
at each other like,
"Yeah it'll get like that."
Here's what I compare it to.
Tell me if it's
true for you guys.
You know those nature videos
where a lion or tiger
will kill some animal
like a zebra and for a
while like kicks and shit
and tries to get 'em off,
but as soon as the lion gets
a really good grad at the neck
the zebra just goes,
"Yeah, whatever bro."
(crowd laughing)
"Do what you gotta
do it's your game."
That's how I was.
Like alright let's
see what happens.
And then out of nowhere,
just out of nowhere.
Their custom's guy, he
just gives me this out.
He was just like,
"Is it possible that
maybe earlier you had
"an apple or something and
then you rested it on the bag?
"Is that possible?"
And I was like...
(crowd laughing)
"Yes. That thing you said
that's what happened to me."
And he just goes, he looks
at me, and just goes,
"Yeah okay."
And he fuckin'
pulled the dog away.
I was so worried I got the
fuck out of there instantly.
Yeah, my friends are like,
"See that's proof that you
shouldn't do that shit,
"you shouldn't smuggle
drugs in with you."
And I was like,
"Nope, that's a case
"where I did not
get in trouble."
There were no
repercussions, of course
I'm going to
continue doing that.
(crowd laughing)
The only person I feel
bad for in the story,
the only one I feel
bad for is the dog.
The dog must have been like,
"What the fuck else
do I have to do?
"We agreed upon a signal.
"I'll go like this
when I find drugs.
"What was I doing? I was
giving you the signal.
"Here are the drugs, here
are the drugs I keep saying.
"You keep bringing up apples.
"Nobody gives a shit about
apples bro. They're legal here."
(crowd laughing)
Alright thank you
very much everybody.
(techno music)